okay Simon can you just tell us a little
bit about the project and how it came
about yeah sure we've been doing it
three three and a half years now it was
brainchild of Deborah's the chair and
her son Dan and really before here
before was just a patch of tarmac it's a
metal ramps I've been here for 14 15
years served its time served its purpose
so let's say three three and a half
years ago we started collecting
fundraising with a goal in mind to
achieve and there's a long sod a long
long time so tell us a little bit about
the challenges that you had to face well
probably a year 18 months ago we had the
money secured everything was in place
and then we discovered drains and
culverts that ran across the site so we
had to take those into account there was
a private housing estate that got in
them not physically got in the way with
the drains within the ways we have to
dive up those and it put us back and
because it put us back we lost 20,000 in
funding which we had to recover a
further 20,000 working the team was
District Council the funding agency
supporting them just to try and retain
the money and even to the point of
finishing this we were within a week of
losing possibly another 50,000 pounds so
yeah okay so tell us what sorts of
efforts the young people from ashburton
have put into this project they revolve
from the start it was very much laid by
the youth group that the supporters it
came to the meetings I met with the
designers came up with the composer's
what it was they looking for a sort of
dream was really they did a lot of the
steering they reviewed the designs and
you know as well as you know bag packing
at Sainsbury's in Tescos and baking
cakes and selling them and christmas
markets and all the stuff that they got
involved in their overall that the use
of the youth the user group raised for
the 15,000 in our own in our own ways so
tell us how the young people have taken
to the new skate park here today well
and I can only go on what you see before
you know the success of it I think it
opened over the summer and one
individual I know was up at three
o'clock in the morning with his rucksack
on waiting to come down here and since
then I think they've been here ever
since this has been a really good
community project for parents as well as
young people the whole community you've
got got behind this well I think so I
mean
I've been very impressed by the way that
seems to have happened and unsolicited
you had we had the W I decided to adopt
barroners as one of their charitably
wanted to support for a whole year so
they gave us the proceeds of their
fundraising efforts at the other end of
the scale the ashburton Family Services
who run woodlanders and the play groups
they've been really enthusiastic and
again the children were involved in
penny spirals and all sorts of
fundraising louise's and help it along
so I've been delighted and the police
and the secondary in the primary schools
everybody seems to recognize it as a
good thing I mean I won't say I'm Jamie
84 safe and everybody's always you know
one hundred percent enthusiastic but
they can see the real benefits of having
a facility like this in the outdoors for
young people you just tell me your name
and your role on the committee my name
is Francois Shelvin and I'm the vice
chair and I have been for three and a
half years since we started raising
funds for the skatepark so tell us a
little bit about what this project means
to ashburton I think it's given the
young people a place to congregate and
to do something that's healthy and
outdoors in the fresh air rather than
just sort of hanging around on street
corners being a bit of a nuisance
sometimes I'm not saying that they are a
nuisance but maybe that's what some
people's view is of young people and I
just feel like there needs really need
to be catered for and I'm just ecstatic
that they've got somewhere where they
can practice improve their moves show
off to each other I think it's great for
their self-esteem to be improving all
the time as well and to have something
that that's a space for them where they
don't have adults kind of pitching in
all the time you know I think in the
past young people they had that they had
when I was a kid we had this light wild
but land across the road and it was
known as the jungle we used to hang out
there it was just a little patch but for
us it was our adventure playground and I
feel really sad that that's been lost
for young people I think it's vital for
their confidence for social skills for
all sorts of skills that they're given
this kind of opportunity ok so what
motivated you to get involved in this
project well partly i was listening to
a lady a garden design conference
several years ago and she was talking
about children and she said that
free-range chickens in the UK have more
legal right and access to outdoor space
and fresh air than our children do and
when I heard that I was really you know
very taken aback and I just thought it's
time to do something about that you know
that's there's something wrong if free
chicken if free-range chickens have more
right to being outdoors than our
children do yeah absolutely thank you
very much I'm very good answer listen